esta es una conferencia de prensa
presidencial muy poco habitual ya gic
bukele presidente del salvador desde
2019 ha sido el mayor promotor del
bitcoin en el país centroamericano una
de las primeras cripto monedas fundada
en 2009
[Aplausos]
desde septiembre pasado el salvadora con
gel bitcoin como moneda oficial junto al
dólar estadounidense y es aquí en esta
playa donde todo comenzó hace dos años
el zonte una pequeña población la
primera en usar este cripto activo
entonces le voy a pagar reina cuando
jorge creó la aplicación bitcoin bitch
yo quiero pagar mi cuenta esta sus
direcciones de iguales entonces puede
venir de directamente tu teléfono
escanear tiene ahora la dirección de la
persona poner por ejemplo 100 80 de mi
transacción se ha realizado envía dos
mil 180 dólares
bitcoin una comida una soda una recarga
telefónica se puede pagar por este medio
de buen beneficio para como un ahorro
porque no sé a ella desde lo del negocio
ella cobra acá pero eso no lo toca y ahí
lo deja
ahora tenemos un método de ahorrar en
nuestra comunidad tenemos nuestros
propios fondos guardados en nuestras
cuentas electrónicas no dependemos de ir
a un banco perder el tiempo para
depositar el dinero y si pensaba que la
script o monedas era el tema de las
nuevas generaciones
fue la primera en aceptar viejo en mamá
rosa aún cocinan con leña pero pagan sus
facturas con dinero digital
a decir verdad nadie sabía que era les
explicaron verdad que era alguna
moneda electrónica compré dos backups
que de otra manera no hubiera podido
comprar pero al salir del pont el
bitcoin se ha quedado muy rezagado este
ha sido uno de los temas en la esquina y
que le ha tenido mano de hierro a pesar
de su aspecto hipster el sector privado
lamenta que esta revolución monetaria se
haya puesto en marcha sin consultarlos
los tres meses que siguieron antes de
que entrar en vigencia esta ley fueron
sumamente caóticos porque la verdad es
que lo que hubo es
silencio del estado
y solo las amenazas de que teníamos que
estar listos para aceptar y recibir
bitcoin como moneda de curso legal en
menos de tres meses lo cual implicaba
desarrollar software hacer inversiones
hacer capacitaciones decisiones
precipitadas fallas de seguridad y miles
de casos de fraude en la aplicación
chivo wallet lanzada por el gobierno han
sido denunciados a pesar de los 30
dólares en bitcoin que ofrece el
gobierno a todos los salvadoreños
aceptación en la población no ha sido la
esperada en marzo pasado el 86% de las
empresas afirmaron que no habían
realizado una transacción en cripto
monedas en san miguel la segunda ciudad
del país aún reina el papel moneda
cuando vieron los 30 dólares que daba el
gobierno yo la use pero ya después de
eso ya no la seguir usando porque no
tengo quemas de remesas no tengo que más
hacer una población reticente pero el
alcalde wil salgado sabe que las nuevas
monedas tienen ventajas las
transacciones son instantáneas gratuitas
y libres de impuestos ahora o no por acá
esto es una bendición para todos los que
viven de las remesas dinero que envían
familia emigrado a eeuu la remesa para
para nosotros los que somos vendedores
porque ellos venden
prácticamente es como la gasolina para
un vehículo y pues te lo manda para allá
porque
tengo una hermana y tú no solo hermano
eso si imposible que haya alguien que no
tenga un familiar a laura' recibe
remesas de su hermano en bitcoin a
través de la aplicación luego puede
convertirlos en dólares en centros
autorizados
ante ellos también para un costo
adicional verdad de para enviarlo pero
hoy con esta aplicación éste no se tiene
que pagar de costo mientras que los
locales aún no están entusiasmados con
la experiencia para cientos de
entusiastas del bitcoin el país se ha
convertido en la nueva tierra prometida
de una nueva era aquel bitcoin en la
moneda oficial en australia perdemos
mucho dinero en impuestos cuando
convertimos nuestros discos
bitcoin es el futuro esta fecha
las monedas tradicionales como el dólar
o la libra se desplomaran
en
un centro atractivo para turistas e
inversores mientras que cada año miles
de salvadoreños huyen por la pobreza y
la violencia es la paradoja de un país
que busca una nueva vía de desarrollo